[Music]
my next guest very talented comedian who
is headlining the punch comedy show at
the cap city comedy club in austin texas
on may 29th please welcome very funny
john ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks guys thanks
i uh i had a conversation the other day
that frustrated me because the person i
was talking to argued that racism is
dead and i know that's not true because
my grandparents are still alive
matter of fact i'm kind of waiting for
racism to die so i can get a new truck
that'd be nice though in the future if
we all get along and the people in the
future don't know what we dealt with but
that's how we are with ancient man like
we don't know their daily struggles and
tragedies like we have no idea how many
good men had to die vomit or hallucinate
before we came across the portobello and
button mushrooms
and even that guy had to be like are
these really good or am i just still
imagining things
but that was a trial and error process
that mankind had to go through to figure
out like what was edible and what would
leave a family fatherless and i'm i'm
glad to be alive today
i'll tell you what when i think about
that
i got a lot of respect
a lot of respect
for the first guy to dig into a
pineapple
have you seen a pineapple i would have
guessed poisonous i might have guessed
reptile on the pineapple that's a
ferocious piece of fruit and yet
somewhere way back when the gauntlet of
time some guy came across a pineapple
and was like
i don't know
what's going to happen to me
but what i do know is that that
must end up here via
this and he ate it
and he was rewarded with golden
deliciousness
and the respect of all the village
and the guiding the pine cone the week
before was like oh so close
i think we're still having problem with
fruit today in the 21st century i am
i'll be honest i cannot get the timing
right on bananas they will turn on you
don't buy bananas unless you have
definite immediate and unshakeable plans
to eat bananas
like i won't even go by the banana aisle
unless i've committed myself to eating
bananas while i buy bananas
so i used to go with some vague notion
that i might want a banana in the future
and i'd go with banana isle and i'd be
like
which one
of you bunches of bananas
has the combination i need of yellow and
green and yellow green
pick out some beautiful yellow bananas
i buy them
by the time i get them to the car one of
them's already like
[Laughter]
you might want to hurry up
what the heck
i race home i try to avoid speed bumps
but i can't help it i live next to a
school
i'm packing my my groceries i get that
banana is just like
john
what do you know about making banana
bread
don't you talk like that
[Applause]
what i really came here to say is that
i'm tired
of being treated like an idiot because i
believe in unicorns
it's a horse for the horn why is that so
magical right it's not like i believe in
centaurs there's all kinds of questions
with centaurs like like how does a human
heart pump blood to a horse body right
is it rude to charge a pet deposit
if you ride one is that horseback or
piggy back there's all kinds of
questions with centaurs i'm done with a
horse with a horn why wouldn't that
exist like you know what is out there
weird things like in the deep sea
there's things like 90 nostril 10 desk
lamp and they're so ugly it's like are
they ugly because they're down there or
down there because they're ugly but
they're down there
you know this is down there a seahorse
that's 50
fish 50 horse
and i'm just talking about something
that's 99 percent of horse
one percent cooler horse
you know since down there there's a
narwhal in the deep sea that's a whale
with a horn anyone makes fun of you
because you have a narwhal on your
trapper keeper at work like what is with
this smear campaign against unicorns
people like what john what what do they
poop glitter i'm like uh
if they eat glitter like
like like what john what what do they
fart rainbows i'm like if there's
moisture in backlighting that's science
thanks guys
you've convinced me
great arguments john ramsey that was
really funny